Hello everyone! Welcome to the LangFocus channel,
and my name is Paul.
Today we are going to talk about
the language of pigeons.
Not funny, bro.
Sorry, I know that joke isn't very good,
but that's all I've got.
Today, I'm going to talk about some special kind
of languages, called Pidgins and Creoles.
You've probably heard thoses terms before.
Maybe in the names of certain languages,
like Pidgin English or Haitian Creole,
but please note, there is not just a single
pidgin language or a single creole language.
They are actually refering to categories of languages.
There are many pidgins
and many creoles around the world.
First, what do they have in common?
Well, Pidgins and Creoles
are new languages that developped
when speakers of different languages come into contact
with each other and have a need to communicate.
Many Pidgins and Creoles  have arisen  when
colonial powers came into contact with local people,
as they spread around the world.
So, what is the difference between Pidgins and Creoles?
Well, Pidgins are non native lingua francas
while Creoles have native speakers.
But let me get into both types of languages.
Okay
First of all, pidgin languages.
As I just mentioned,
pidgin languages have no native speakers.
They are languages
that arise very suddenly, very quickly,
when there is a need of  communication
in a certain situation.
For example, for trade or for labour.
The Pidgin language is a sort of compromise between
two different languages or between multiple languages.
Pidgins usually arise when one group of people is
dominant over another group of people,
and the less dominant group needs to learn
to communicate with the more dominant group.
But, without any formal education
in the language of that dominant group,
they adopt a sort of simplified language based on the
most basic vocabulary of that dominant group's language
and based on the most basic grammar
of their own native language.
This happens most commonly in situations
of trade, slavery or colonial contact.
And in a situation like that, the dominant group is usually
the colonial power or the most influential trading partner.
Imagine this situation: an English-speaking
colonial power has a sugar plantation
and they bring over labourers from various
different countries to that sugar plantation
and those people speak different languages.
But, in order to work together,
they need to have a common language.
So they try to adopt English, but since they do this quickly,
and they just adopt the basics,
the resulting language is a very simplified language,
just using the basic vocabulary of English
and a very non English grammar.
That is a Pidgin language.
Got it!
When Pidgins first developped,
they are typically restricted in use.
Meaning that they are only used for a certain purpose.
For example, on the job or for trade.
But some Pidgins become expanded Pidgins, meaning
that they begin to be used for all facettes of life
including social life, family life, things like that,
and they become languages in their own rights.
Even though they are not native languages,
they are passed down from generation to generation
as lingua francas among people
who speak different native languages
Now about Creole languages.
So, Pidgins have no native speakers.
They arise because the need for a lingua franca,
but if that language survives and becomes
the native language of the next generation,
then it is now a Creole language.
For example, slaves from several different countries
are working closely together on a plantation,
but they have no common language.
So, they develop their Pidgin
and it quickly becomes their expanded Pidgin,
the language they use for all everyday purposes.
Their children grow up in that environment with
that Pidgin language and it becomes their native language.
That is now a Creole language.
In the days when African slaves
were brought to the Americas,
they were often separated from people
who spoke the same native language.
That was to prevent them from rebelling
or from making plans together, that kind of things.
So, in those kinds of situations,
the Pidgin languages became expanded very quickly
and, within one generation,
sometimes became Creoles.
Some Creoles are based on English.
For example, Jamaican Creole.
Some Creoles are based on French,
Including Haitian Creole,
which has 12 million native speakers.
And the smaller number of Creole languages
are based on Spanish,
including Chavacano, in the Philippines.
Now, how different are these Creole languages
from their parent languages?
Well, it depends of the particular language;
but let's look at an example.
This example is from Bislamá, which is
an English-based Creole spoken in Vanuatu.
The first sentence is "This is my house"
In Bislamá: "Hem ya haos blong mi".
Or in more Standard English phonology :
"Him here house belong me"
Another example sentence:
"I have already been to town"
In Bislamá: "Mi bin long taon finis".
Or in Standard English phonology :
"Me been long town finish"
So look at each word : "Mi" is like "I",
"bin", that's self-explanatory.
"long" is used as a preposition here instead
of an adjective. So "long" means "towards" or "to"
And then, we have "taon", that is like "town"
and "finis". "finis" is used instead of "already"
to show that something has been accomplished.
So, again you can see that the words are from English
but they are used and arranged in a very different way,
and this is what makes it a different language
than the parent language.
Pidgins and Creoles are fascinating because they are
proof that languages are living entities,
that are constantly changing and adapting
to the needs of their speakers.
Sometimes, two or more languages can even join forces
and take on a life of their own as a new language.
Thank you for watching.
Be sure to leave your comments down below.
And have a nice day.